did you guys know that originally will smith
was approached by quentin tarantino to play
django and django unchained and he turned down the
role he recently talked about well not recently
but like a couple years ago we talked about it in
an interview of one of those actors roundtables
it had to be a love story not a vengeance story
oh i don't believe in violence as the reaction
okay ladies and gentlemen okay so i just got
back from an oscar's party now generally i've
kind of given up on the oscars i think they can
be quite boring the awards don't really mean much
to me i haven't even seen most of the films that
actually came out that were nominated to be honest
so in my mind i was like look this i'm just going
to hang out with some friends i was surprisingly
getting most of my picks right because the
officers can be really predictable when it
comes to nominations and stuff and then the
greatest thing in oscar's history ever happened
this is a night to remember ladies and gentlemen
history memes for weeks the most talked about
thing on the internet like i thought the most
talked about thing coming out of the oscars
would be that random category they were presenting
for like fan favorite cheer moment and then zack
sanders justice league one and then fan favorite
movie and zack snyder's army of the dead one i
was like this is where all the talk on twitter
is gonna be about it's gonna be all about this
i was wrong like 10 minutes later i was way wrong
in case you guys don't know i'm so shocked if you
don't but in case you guys don't know chris
rock presented an award for best documentary
i believe that was the category and then he was
making some jokes it's chris rocker expecting to
make some jokes he made some jokes about penelope
cruz and hobby of our damn couples jokes as chris
rock likes to make couples jokes will smith
jada pinkett smith sitting front row at the
oscars he made a joke about jada pinkett smith
saying i can't wait to see you in g.i jane too
apparently big willy got provoked smack the crap
out of chris rock and change oscars forever set a
precedent apparently you can go up to people smack
the presenter and nothing's gonna happen to you
depending on your star level and the clout you
have for that night and the fact that you're
gonna win an award that evening it it was wild
i'm gonna ask you guys right up front what did you
think about what happened what was your reaction
to it how do you feel overall who was right who
was wrong i want to hear your thoughts in the
comments below i'm going to talk you guys through
my reaction of experiencing this and then i'm also
going to give some of my thoughts and feelings on
it as well the officers are going they're going
fine it's actually a pretty enjoyable oscars for
the most part amy schumer's doing a great job
when chris rock is out there presenting the
award he's doing his speech and then here's what
happened he makes the g.i jane joke and i can't
i could show you some footage but i can't play it
because i know this video will get blocked because
i know abc is he makes the joke and then at first
will smith he's laughing he's laughing so i was
like everything just seems fine he's laughing
about it jada pinkett smith evidently not happy at
all it is so apparent she is not happy cuts back
to chris rock he's doing his thing and the crowd
at first is going oh and chris rock said something
to the effect of like it was a light one or
whatever like it wasn't that bad of a joke and in
my mind like it's not that bad of a joke she has a
she has a shaved head and then he said gij like
that's an old ass movie like this is a stupid
joke will smith starts walking up to him you see
chris rock laughing his ass off at will smith
approaching him we only see the back of will smith
said so we don't know what will smith's face looks
like in that moment so will smith walks up to him
chris roger leaned in almost as if he's like come
on in and hit me like his face is leaned in with
laughter i thought will smith was just gonna get
on the mic or some [ __ ] i thought that's all he
was gonna do was just freaking like start making a
joke or make a joke about chris rock or whatever
all of a sudden bam oh wow like the perfect form
perfect form the all lead days of will smith come
out it was a great hit all things considered you
know it's great assault yes but a great hit
over probably smith then he goes back down
now if you live in australia you got the
uncensored version and apparently you can
find the audio the actually uncensored version on
sites like youtube and twitter but in the states
in our mind when he smacked him it looked like
a bit because you know like chris rock didn't
fall down or whatever all of us thought it was
like some weird joke and chris rock says will
smith just smacked the um out of me that's how it
sounded to us and then all the audio went out and
you're cutting back to will smith who's looking
pissed off and you can see chris rock feeling
pretty awkward about the whole ordeal and then
it starts to register with us like i think this
is actually very real i think will smith just
got really mad about a joke that he just seemed
like fine with a second ago and then got up there
got very reactive and smacked the [ __ ] out of
chris rock here's what i think really happened at
least this is how what what i in the moment what
i thought happened chris rock made a funny will
smith laughed at the funny looked to his wife
wife didn't find it funny well smith
realized i'm gonna be in the doghouse
unless i do something about this i gotta stand
up for her because i know what it's like when
you're in a relationship and you think something's
funny that your significant other doesn't that's
at the expense of her then you're like oh [ __ ]
i shouldn't have laughed at that i need to correct
this now so he did the one thing he could do walk
up on stage and smack the [ __ ] out of chris
that's how it just registered to me in the moment
it was crazy and what made it crazier we went
crazier for all of us is the fact that we all knew
will smith was going to win that night there was
no question about it so it just made it go out
of all nights like it's already a bad night to do
like you never just want to do that but out of any
night to do this on the night you're finally going
to win your oscar this happens like what is your
speech going to be what is your speech going to
be so on the uncensored version when i watched it
on the car ride home after chris rock says will's
just smacked the [ __ ] out of me will smith says
keep my wife's name out of your [ __ ] mouth chris
rock was like dude it was a g.i jane joke at
the time i was like considering the same thing
dude she's a gi jin joe chill out you're a couple
who's in the public spotlight like all the time
your relationship seems to be like on blast you
even did a sit-down interview where you really
exposed a lot of things about your relationship
right away when you're that level of celebrity
and you're allowing yourself to be that exposed
usually that means like entertainers comedians
people are going to make jokes at you and just
kind of kind of be ready for it if you're going to
be willing to expose that society that's just
how i was registering at the time there was
other information that was yet to learn but
at the time that's how i was thinking about
it will smith did further in real anger
like rage keep my wife's name out of your
mouth if i say too hard youtube gets a little
sentimental about the whole thing and then chris
rock made a little crack of this was the best
night in television history or so you made a joke
about something like that it is it made the oscars
truly exciting more exciting than it's ever been
that was crazy so come to find out uh i did not
know this apparently jada has actually been very
public about this but i don't follow the lives
of them the question is did chris rock know about
this says she has a disease called alopecia
it's medical term for baldness so she suffers
from baldness so it's not her fault that she's
bald it's a condition that she has and that's
really unfortunate and that just changes the
whole context of the joke right there there's
several ways comedian because comedians seem
to always be defending themselves against like
the free will to make a joke about anything and
anybody i get that a lot of comedians feel that
way so i i don't know if chris rock didn't knew
that or not or he did know that and he was like
i can still make a joke anyway because i don't
think the joke's that bad that is a very sensitive
thing to say in front of like millions of people
it's not really about what chris rock believes if
that's offensive or not it's more about how will
the person on the receiving end of that comment
how will they feel about that and if jada's the
kind of individual to be hurt and offended by that
then you shouldn't make that joke especially
if you already know that she has this disease
that she probably would not want to be made fun
about and one of the biggest nights in their life
because they're husband and wife just having the
spotlight put on you like that see i i can get
that the question is should will smith walked
up there and smack the [ __ ] out of chris rock
probably not that was probably not the way to
handle it i know that there's most likely a lot
of women across the world a lot of people maybe
not just women but a lot of men too who are like
you know if i was made fun of in public i would
expect my man to go up there and just beat the
[ __ ] out of that guy and to me i'm like well it
really depends on the situation at hand you know
if this is the oscars yeah i might mike i might
give a look like i'm pretty upset by that joke but
i'm not going to go up there and smack the guy i
mean hey i could get i could get arrested or fined
for assault or something like that like this this
is not a good look and then it just started making
me kill the fact that will smith just kind of got
away with it started making me go too does will
smith just like do this does he when he gets mad
at people does he just smack them like has he's
just smacked people on set before like what's his
attitude like if there's a joke that's made that
you just you just can't roll with because it comes
in the name of protection and love because he gave
this speech and in between before his oscar win
his publicist was talking to him a lot there's
like photos of like denzel talking to him and
tyler perry i believe like there's there's people
congregating with him to talk him through it and
seem like there was a lot of people in support of
him in that moment you know like he got sensitive
he was provoked something happened and you're in
a room full of a bunch of artists who are all very
sensitive individuals who also practice the art of
empathy they're not going to be like social media
about it you know they're all there's going to be
a lot more understanding they probably know
will they definitely know will smith better
than either one of us makes sense how he's
going to have a lot of support surrounding
him in a moment like that and it seems like a
lot we're on a side at least that's the way it
appeared that was the impression given off so will
smith gives his speech you know we're all like
what's he going to say you know what's will
smith going to talk about is he going to is
he metro chris rock he's going to talk [ __ ]
about it he immediately starts to talk about
people he had to protect people involved with the
movie characters real life people talking about
how love makes you do crazy things and the
way he gave his speech made our friend brandon
hannah in the roommate the best comment ever
that man has a damn good publicist he really
does because holy balls it was a great speech
there's still like when you revisit the situation
that happened i'm like does the speech eliminate
you know all with everything that happened no it
definitely doesn't in the moment of time you're
like damn that's a powerful speech it seems really
sincere seems very emotional and i at least get
where he's coming from at this moment in time
and it seemed like at least the way the narrative
suddenly changed on that it was all coming from
a place of not necessarily ego but a place of
protecting a loved one and especially when you
find out that jada has alopecia you're like okay
like he was really going out there protecting her
i still think there are other ways it could
have been handled but he had a human moment
he's human i've met plenty of people who've
started a fight they shouldn't have had they
felt like they regretted that they maybe shouldn't
have done it wilson apologized to the academy
he apologized to his to his fellow nominees didn't
apologize chris rocco but he apologized to other
people and i'm wondering too like is there more
history with him in chris rock because i know that
like a few years ago when it came to the whole
boycott in the oscar situation chris rock when
he was hosting the oscars made a joke directed at
them wasn't about this but he made a joke at them
so maybe there's more of a history there that we
don't really know i think he could have handled
it differently i think he could have like you know
like at least displayed that he wasn't happy with
it hell if you even if he just yelled instead
of you know actually going there and hitting
him because that is an act of violence that's bad
it's like that thing of like dude i totally get
it you were standing up for the woman you love
i totally understand you guys have had a lot of
heat on you and there's always seems like the
media is trying to take you guys down so you're
protecting her in this moment that's supposed
to just be a beautiful night like i get it you
probably shouldn't have smacked her chris rock you
probably shouldn't have made that joke but you're
like whoa guys both of you probably shouldn't have
done this i totally understand that regardless how
do i feel about this it weirdly made for the most
entertaining night in oscar history like this was
uh this was a night to remember it was it was wild
and that fact that that [ __ ] got put on display
good job to will smith's publicist good job to a
support team congratulations will smith on winning
that oscar and man i would never [ __ ] with that
guy it's just crazy because he always comes across
as like the nicest dude ever he oh and even
in that moment you're just like he seemed like
he was just protecting her but holy crap like
he'll just go up to you and hit you if you do
something wrong that was uh that was that was
pretty crazy i just thought i'm gonna be like
thinking about this all the time and talking about
it for a very long time so i just want to hop
on camera but you guys talking about it really
quick thanks for being here chit chat soon you